bonsoir félicitations merci beaucoup
c'est pas des petits trophées on
s'attendait aux échecs d'avoir quelque
chose de c'est un gros trophée
impressionnant oui c'est ça fait du bien
de recevoir des trophées comme ça ils
sont difficiles à ramener à la maison
d'aller dans les bagages mais c'est
agréable de recevoir comme ça bon on
tenait à faire le point avec toi parce
que c'est quand même un accomplissement
extraordinaire la tuer au sommet de ton
art je sais pas si je peux appeler ça un
arbre mais oui
raconte-moi un peu tu joues depuis quel
âge j'ai commencé à jouer quand j'avais
6 ans dans le fond quand j'étais en
première année à mon école primaire mais
je voyais mes amis jouer aux échecs et
moi je connaissais pas du tout les
règles et je voulais vraiment apprendre
à jouer pour jouer avec eux je vais
s'inscrit en parascolaire et je vais la
piqûre j'ai eu la passion qui est
toujours gardé cette passion depuis à
quel moment tu t'es aperçu que tu avais
un talent certain là que tu avais le
cerveau pour ça
dès mon premier tournoi je dirais je
pense que j'avais encore 16 ans en ce
moment-là j'ai gagné toutes mes parties
donc c'était
par la suite j'ai eu quelques moments
quelques temps un peu plus difficile
mais je pense que j'ai toujours la
passion que j'ai toujours j'ai toujours
su que j'aimais beaucoup les échecs bon
et là au dernier tournoi que tu viens de
remporter tu n'as pas perdu aucune
partie non cette victoire est 4 nuls
dans les 11 parties bon c'est des
joueurs très forts c'est un peut pas
être plus haut calibre que ça ouais non
c'est le tournoi était vraiment relevé
clairement indépendant les plus les plus
forts que j'ai joué de toute ma carrière
à l'autre est-ce que au Québec on a
l'infrastructure les clubs nécessaires
pour que des talents comme le tien
fleurissent comme ça de façon
extraordinaire je sais qu'au Québec on a
quand même beaucoup de ressources mais
c'est sûr que c'est pas autant que qu'on
Europe ou que dans certains pays d'Asie
mais ou même qu'aux Etats-Unis donc
c'est sûr que selon moi c'est plus
facile de voyager pour obtenir pour
pouvoir jouer dans certaines tournois
prestigieux mais je pense que la
situation c'est que au Québec
est-ce qu'on a des bons joueurs beaucoup
Québec est-ce que tu as assez de joueurs
quand tu restes ici pour jouer ou tu
joues en ligne avec des joueurs de
manière continue un peu des deux j'aime
beaucoup jouer en ligne pour jouer plus
régulièrement contre des adversaires
plus forts je pense que c'est une bonne
pratique mais au Québec on a quand même
des joueurs assez de niveau assez élevés
ton
idole c'est Magnus Carlsen qui était le
moi mon époque c'est Kasparov là des des
Russes comme ça mais quand ça ne vient
de dire aujourd'hui qu'il quitte le
monde des échecs il s'est fait battre
par un jeune de 19 ans
qu'est-ce que tu en dis ben je suis un
peu triste de cette nouvelle là je crois
pas qu'il quitte le monde des échecs par
contre mais je pense qu'il était
vraiment déçu de sa défaite
d'ailleurs il y a eu quelques
instinations qui sont deversatriché
peut-être donc c'est sûr que c'est
difficile à entendre des choses comme ça
donc c'est très dommage pour Carson lui
c'est le top des tops pour toi là c'est
le champion toute catégorie
ton âge je pense pas au plus vieux que
moi j'entais avec les casse-parents avec
etc là non lui car ce champion du monde
depuis 9 ans et c'est incontestablement
le meilleur joueur sur la planète en ce
moment
donc ça c'est pour moi c'est vraiment
une passion de le suivre tout le temps
suivre ses résultats c'est vraiment
sûrement un modèle pour moi en tant que
joueur est-ce que les échecs moi je ne
sais pas jouer aux échecs je le
reconnais désolé
est-ce que plus âgé c'est un sport qu'on
peut apprendre c'est un jeu qu'on peut
apprendre tu crois oui c'est sûr que on
peut la prendre à n'importe quel âge
même je connais des gens qui l'ont
appris assez tard mais qui sont devenus
des très bons joueurs mais d'un autre
côté je pense que c'est quand même
apprendre une langue ou apprendre un
instrument de musique je pense que c'est
toujours plus facile de commencer qu'on
est jeune et
ouais c'est sûr et du fait que tu es un
bon joueur quelle qualité tu as pour
devin le jeu tu vois
plusieurs coups d'avance bien sûr tu as
une capacité de
calcul mental et finis quoi bon j'ai
quand même pas je pense que c'est comme
un combinaison plusieurs facteurs je
pense que la discipline la concentration
c'est je pense que c'est deux choses qui
sont importantes pour un jour d'échec
mais comme vous avez dit le calcul c'est
vraiment important aussi
de
mais à ton niveau là vous êtes vous vous
parlez vous avez une connexion j'imagine
à ce niveau là de joueurs là ouais non
c'est sûr je pense que les wesh je pense
que le calcul puis aussi je dirais ça va
gérer la pression je pense que c'est
quelque chose que j'ai appris qui était
assez important après plusieurs défaites
quand j'étais jeune dans les moments
importants je pense que c'est c'est
quelque chose qui m'a rendu qui m'a fait
passer une étape supérieure selon moi
bon là quels sont les prochaines étapes
justement c'est comme le sport d'élite
il y a des universités américaines qui
ont des clubs d'échecs qui recherchent
des joueurs comme toi donc tu auras tu
as devant toi plein de portes qui
s'ouvrent et jusqu'où tu veux aller mon
objectif ultime ça serait le titre de
Grand Maître qui est justement le titre
le plus haut qu'on peut atteindre aux
échecs pour avoir cette idée là il faut
faire dans le fond ce qu'on appelle des
normes il en faut trois et des normes
c'est des performances de certains
niveaux puis qui doivent respecter
certains critères par exemple il faut
jouer contre un certain de différents
pays il faut juste continuer une moyenne
de niveau d'adversaire assez élevé aussi
donc ça ils font obtenir trois
performances comme ça et je viens d'en
obtenir justement Roumanie donc j'espère
obtenir les deux autres
idéalement peut-être et est-ce que tu
seras courtisé par des campus américains
pour aller faire des études
universitaires pour t'inscrire à leur
club d'échec parce que eux veulent
redorer leur club oui j'ai déjà reçu une
offre justement dans les derniers jours
après mon tournoi
décidément des opportunités c'est sûr
c'est c'est j'envisage clairement de
d'accepter ces offres là c'est sûr que
c'est difficile de changer de pays de
déménager comme ça mais c'est ça
représente une belle opportunité parce
que c'est le genre de choses qu'on ne
peut pas faire facilement dans
universités québécois j'imagine non
c'est sûr que les programmes d'échec
sont tellement développés dans les
universités au Québec mais ça reste que
c'est
il y a quand même des des tournois
d'échec inter-universaires au Canada par
exemple qui sont assez intéressants bon
Charles explique-moi qui de l'homme ou
de la machine et le meilleur à ce jeu-là
à l'époque là
des Blue qui a battu casse-parents qui
était furieux que
la machine arrive maintenant à vous
battre oui c'est sûr la machine pourrait
jouer contre le meilleur joueur de tous
les temps autant de fois qu'il le veut
je pense que ce serait seulement des
victoires pour la machine avec la
technologie qui est ici avancée
aujourd'hui
les ordinateurs sont capables de choses
inimaginables donc l'intelligence
artificielle a fait en sorte que
désormais la machine était battable
qu'un humain ne peut pas déjouer la
machine avec des des coups hors normes
pour ensuite la surprendre non je crois
que le
la force brute des machines sont en 2022
et beaucoup trop forte pour celle d'un
humain
c'est ça les machines sont vraiment un
niveau supérieur aujourd'hui bon mais
merci d'être venu sur notre plateau
l'excellence dans tous les domaines
s'intéressant de de voir des exemples
concrets chez nous à côté chambre
Rodrigue le mieux champion du monde des
échecs chez les moins 18 ans bonne
chance pour la suite on va suivre votre
carrière merci beaucoup